ludicrous well lit
that's natural lighting it's out it's a
window in front of me that's all it is
natural atlanta lighting
right right um so i know you're a dad
and i know that your kids mean the world
to you when i think of ludicrous though
i think of someone
very animated you know very colorful
what kind of dad are you though i'm very
colorful and very animated dad that's
literally how i am i'm the same way
always energetic you know always the
life of the party and i think it rubs
off on my kids because they never want
to go to sleep so there you have it
that'll let you know what type of dad i
am for sure for sure
yeah yeah you're the fun dad absolutely
and you know me i have you got to be the
fun dad that's and i have all girls too
so you know it's important
i haven't had a chance to wear you know
since i don't have any boys i don't i
i don't really have to oh speak of
whoa what is wrong right here
wait a second you see daddy's actually
doing a live interview right now
so i i if you don't mind can i uh can i
finish we were just talking about what
type of data am i
good daddy
thank you
oh my gosh you could choose to use it or
you could edit it but that's
priceless she literally opened the door
in my office and just
barged in this is what happens you see
what i'm talking about
craziness he runs it she runs it
so what i was saying was yeah what i was
saying was i have all girls and they
haven't
they're not bad you know what i mean
that so so i haven't had a chance to be
extremely strict you know every now and
then i have to put them in their place
but for the most part
they don't do anything to have me be a
mean dad or a bad dad or like
extremely extremely strict on them they
all pretty good
i love that um i know you started a
website
that you that you co-founded called kid
nation um
what inspired it and what is the overall
goal of kidnation
so what inspired it was my children man
it was actually my my oldest daughter
when she was six years old she used to
come in my studio and say daddy i want a
rap
and i would kind of kick her out and
then she did it so consistently that one
day
i put her in the booth and you know she
her enunciation addiction and on beat
rhythm everything was on point
and i had a conversation with her and i
was like okay if you want to
if you wanna do music daddy talks about
what goes on in his world so you're
gonna have to talk about what goes on in
yours
and that's pretty much just ethics and
morals and
school education of course and all
enriching content so that's where this
idea came about
and i had to think to myself i'm like we
don't really have
current music for kids and bi kids
that's all enriching content so that's
what kidnation.com is all about
i love that and cool music not like
annoying music exactly look
yeah i know exactly what you mean but
yes 100
put it this way we all have we have
music that kids want to listen to that's
mostly adult content but we don't have
kids music that adults love to listen to
as well and just as much as the
as that so there you have it you know
what i mean we're trying to this is
revolutionary and i think the timing
couldn't be more perfect
with everything that's going on because
we have one song and video up as we've
soft launched talking about
staying clean and obviously hygiene and
then about racial injustice one called
get along so a lot of this is just
facilitating the children's thoughts
and ideas and putting them into current
music
yeah um i know through kidnation we get
to see you interacting with your four
beautiful daughters um who as we can see
have you wrapped around your finger
but how does it feel to work alongside
your daughters
no it feels good they're kind of like
more like my tester group so
kid nation is a lot of different
children
coming together it's not just my kids so
not only is it
music by them but it's also live videos
but to answer your question
you know i love that they're my tesla
group so all the videos
go by them first if it doesn't pass the
bridges kids test
then we don't use it here there you go
yeah um are they interested in acting
i know obviously music but um do you see
that
in them wanting to act one hundred
percent they're definitely interested in
right now my oldest who who is 18 she
definitely wants to be in
she's been in theater and she wants to
pursue it and
why you know being in atlanta is a great
place to actually pursue that especially
now because a lot of the movies are
being shot here
my youngest the five and six year old
you know they
they're around the house and they want
to pursue acting yes but right now we
haven't had that serious
conversation yet they're still too young
um so i know a big part of kidnation is
inspiring
and educating and helping kids be the
best they can be and obviously
that is something every parent wants to
do for their kids and inspire them to be
the best they can be
um what do you hope your daughters learn
from you
in terms of the kid nation or just from
me period
you period oh man i could go on and on
about that humbly speaking
um just being a person of their word you
know doing what they say and saying what
they do
and always being humble never get too
big of a head just always be very
strategic
um continue to evolve and learn and
educate
yourself you know until the day you
expire on this earth
uh don't tiptoe through life just to
arrive
safely at at the end of your days
so you know take chances take calculated
risks these are just some of the things
that are off the top of my head but
always respect yourself love yourself
first before you can love anyone else
uh yeah i can go on and on oh my god
you're a fun dad i could just
see it for sure um
so when your young ones say that they
want to get into acting or singing
um what are you going to say to them
yeah i feel like they can pursue
whatever they want to pursue i just give
them all of the facts
and try and give them all of the
information and let them utilize that
information to
to to their advantage and and and to
make
good decisions based off what they want
to do so yeah i don't discourage my kids
from doing you know
anything so to speak if it's something
that they want to do
uh you know beyond reason of course then
i i definitely
will encourage them and try to help them
to do that
yeah um i really love hashtag get along
i love the movement that you're doing on
kidnation
which is obviously about spreading love
and racial equality
um and we've seen so much happen over
the past few weeks with black lives
matter
um how are you feeling with everything
going on
you know it's i'm just as frustrated and
emotional as everyone else
i really am happy about the small
strides that we're making as well and i
do love that it's a new day you've never
seen
this many different ethnicities marching
with uh
you know african americans in this
country as you have
recently so there are a lot of changes
that are being made slow changes
but we're you know it's it's a roller
coaster ride and obviously this is the
beginning and i feel like we have to
continue
we have to continue to do as much as we
can to keep the pressure on because all
of a sudden everyone is listening and
the visible evidence you know with
george floyd's death
it couldn't be more you know just in
your face
and i think the accountability factor is
what's helping a lot as well because
nowadays everybody has their camera
phones out and now it's not just
one person's word against another
person's word
which we all know does never you know it
doesn't go in our favor
so now that you have that visible
evidence it's a great thing
yeah um how do you think this
you know get along movement would have
affected you
as a young black boy growing up in
america it would have been good i think
it would have helped me out a lot just
because the part of the reason of what
we're doing is to spark great
conversations
even if it's with parents and their
children because a lot of times with my
daughters the reason the way i'm able to
talk about difficult circumstances going
on in the world is we watch movies
together
and that can bring up conversations of
if you were put in that position or
something like that happened to you how
would you react
and so this type of music video and
these type of songs should be able to
create those type of conversations
which parents and kids may not normally
have
because it's not like kids just sit
there and want to watch the news with
their parents
and the parents is extremely i mean i'm
sorry the news is can be very negative
as well
i mean yes they're reporting the facts
but you know i wish there was more
positivity that they don't
um that they don't talk about as much as
the negativity and again
kidnapping is all about positivity so
i'm just trying to balance out the world
and try and give them love because i
feel like love trumps hate
you know hate may win some battles but
love always wins the war in the end
kidnation.com is all about love
yeah um is there any advice or any
particular
message you would like to share with
your fans or maybe your fans that have
kids their kids
um just revolving everything that is
going on in america right now because
like you said you're frustrated a lot of
people are are angry they're feeling
really emotional it's a it's a wild time
and
add that with quarantine people are
going through a lot
so people who look to you for
inspiration you know what is something
you'd like to leave them with
i just want to leave them with you are
doing
something like even if it's you know
even if you feel like you want to do so
much more but within your capacity
i feel like we're doing so well at
galvanizing the community together and
starting to make slow change even if
it's something like
blackout day 2020 and supporting black
businesses
or encouraging someone to you know know
the law
and make sure they have their camera
phones out or something recording so
that they can make sure they have
evidence just in case something goes
wrong or holding people accountable
you know what i mean or voting going to
register to vote
all i can do is encourage every single
person to just do
one thing and if we all do one thing
something simple
you have no idea the mountains that we
can move don't be frustrated just
because
you see all this stuff going on and you
feel like you are powerless no you are
powerful
on your own all you got to do is
encourage other people to do positive
things that's what i would leave them
with